pareil on le sait est la capitale
mondiale du tourisme on vient de le voir
mais autour de paris des petites villes
l'ont réussi à développer des circuits
qui marche bien exemple provins en
seine-et-marne avec sa cité médiévale
très visitée durant ce week-end pascal
week-end qui en général marque le début
de la saison touristique code guérini
patrick d'amiens
avant les années 90 prouve à vivoter sur
le moyen-âge depuis 93 la ville entière
fait vivre le moyen-âge en basse saison
comme en haute saison rénovation visites
individuelles ou collectives retraités
familles toute une population bon enfant
du nord-est du bassin parisien
on peut comparer maintenant province un
grand livre ouvert où on peut lire la
vie au moyen âge c'est à dire nous avons
tous les thèmes la vie militaire la vie
économie la vie féodal et tout ça est
concrétisé par des visites et des
spectacles des animations des activités
des chouchous sont les jeunes les écoles
les classes qui ont le moyen-âge à leur
programme mais aucun tourisme ne peut se
satisfaire d'une seule clientèle des
étrangers commencent à venir un peu
grâce au parc d'attractions voisin la
coupe du monde n'a pas encore fait
ressentir tous ses effets mais les
étrangers par la force même du site
celle des animations de qualité des
visites guidées ces étrangers commencent
à s'arrêter il ya des sites importants
touristique en ile-de-france proches de
ceux de provins donc à nous de les faire
venir aussi approuve en leur disant il
ya des choses merveilleuses en
ile-de-france pas loin de provins mais
provins quelque chose de très original
de très beaux et authentique et là je
crois que pour la la clientèle étrangère
pour les touristes étrangers nous avons
des atouts majeurs de 70 mille visites
annuelles payante il y a dix ans à 250
milles derrière la preuve a été faite
que pour être efficace une politique de
tourisme local doit être en synergie
avec les autres pôles il faut du temps
de la volonté des investissements
financiers me mets toutes les villes
n'ont pas la chance et les moyens de
provins